et ruquier la radio ça baisse aussi et
l'année c'est la question du plat de
résistance d'aujourd'hui sur la
négociation de monsieur ruquier a à
france télé on vous dit tournant lui
juste après alors que ces audiences
radio sur les grosses têtes viennent de
tomber sont en baisse
laurent ruquier n'est pas à la fête en
ce moment non plus à la télé à la tête
de deux importantes émissions sur france
2 depuis la rentrée les records se font
rares et les audiences sont plutôt
mitigés d'abord les enfants de la télé
qui samedi soir dernier était
exceptionnellement diffusée en prime
time pour une version spéciale surprise
party l'émission s'est péniblement
classé troisième des audiences avec à
peine 1 million 500 mille
téléspectateurs
mais cette audience décevante n'est pas
tout à fait une surprise car la version
hebdomadaire du programme ne fait guère
mieux alors qu'à son lancement elle
attiré 2,5 millions de fidèles depuis
plusieurs semaines l'émission a du mal à
dépasser les 1.5 million de
téléspectateurs et les 10% de part de
marché de son côté l'émission on n'est
pas couché diffusée chaque samedi soir
en deuxième partie de soirée est passé
samedi dernier sous la barre symbolique
des 900 mille téléspectateurs c'est la
première saison qu'on n'est pas couché
affiche une moyenne en dessous du
million bref des audiences compliqué sur
fond de bras de fer avec la direction
alors selon vous laurent qui est il en
danger sur france 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on va on va relever sa baisse un
peu à la radio ça pèse un peu la télé si
on fait une moyenne moins cher maxime
guennoun alors il fait 800 900 mille
téléspectateurs et dont on n'est pas
couché en dessous d r je mens 2 millions
cette saison et savez combien la 15e
saison - 2 on n'est pas couché
15e saison à meyrueis à carmaux albi le
prg a été rejetée un million cinq c'est
pas c'est pas ou ce non plus sur les
praguois mais après la vitesse de
croisière sur l'access le dimanche a
plutôt bien prise je crois que aussi une
interrogation on n'oublie pas qui fait
partie du groupe rtl il sait pas ce
qu'elle veut dire jouer je vois son oeil
je dois aller qui se remplit d'eau petit
à petit le groupe m6 ne serait pas
intéressé pour le prendre sur l'une de
ses seules infos alors c'est que groupe
m6 ne lui a rien proposé
adaptant aux négociations avec le front
c'est tout c'est un des deux
informations et voilà et dire que perdre
cent mille téléspectateurs c'est énorme
vous y allez un peu fort parce que 900
mille téléspectateurs c'est quand même
pas mal non mr bricolage à milan mais
aussi laurent ruquier laurent ruquier
n'a jamais eu d'énormes succès en prime
quand vous regardez bien ces quinze
dernières années il n'a pas fait de
grands cartons en prime il a fait des
cartons sur les grosses têtes non sur
des marques fortes
on parlera de qui veut gagner des
millions tout à l'heure mais une marque
ça se préserve aussi de ton on est on
est précisément en train de dire qu'on
n'est pas couché par exemple après perdu
un million et un million ces secteurs
non non il va vers du nez ou plus
aujourd'hui aux éditions 2004 a mis en
quatre
là on est à 900 et 2000 15 minutes donc
voilà c'est une baisse relative mais bon
le format et comme il est ce qu'il n'ya
pas besoin de recruter des chroniqueurs
sont des gens qui l'entourent en avant
n'ont pas perdu un peu de cette gestion
oui c'est un problème des aides avec le
rock band chroniqueur il y en a plein
qu'on veut pas voir coller que les
téléspectateurs des tests en même temps
ce sont ses fusibles
c'est ce qui lui permet de tenir donc il
on disait tout à l'heure qu'il est à 14
et 14 ans d'émission 19 ans de service
public est ce qu'il faut rappeler
surtout c'est que si cette émission
étiez encore à mon avis
les enfants de la télé je ne vois pas du
tout cette émission tenir à la rentrée
alors il ya deux infos qui circulent sur
sur sa liasse j'ai entendu dire que les
sondes étaient parrot conduite et
nicolas me dit qu'elle et son est
reconduit son contrat ils sont heureux
négocier le contrat des deux mains
benjamin chaque année à la même époque
c'est un marronnier quoi à chaque fois
on dit ah ça reviendra pas à la rentrée
ça revient toujours c'est un truc
installé moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que
ce soit des chronos et ses chroniqueurs
là qui reviennent pas ah ouais je pense
que christine angot c'est henry hier
soir et c'est impossible trop tôt six
autres c'est le replay parce que on
n'est pas couché est une émission qui
est extrêmement regarder en replay et
des émissions aussi c'est bien mais
c'est pas ça mais vous pouvez pas dire
un mot on donne est passé de un million
quatre en quatre ans leur minois un
moment où les audiences de la télé en
général beth me collard échec c'est pas
du bio n'est plus l'émission qui fait
référence en matière de balance pas pris
le relais hier c'est l'info les gens
veulent mettre à l'essai leur garantisse
à une démission qui qu'on passait
franchement maintenant
barak les chroniqueurs lui aussi les
mauvaises nouvelles
[Musique]
holmes a lancé que valbert ya un moment
donné arrêté aussi d'être il faut pas
caricaturer tous mes amendes et laurent
ruquier c'est un très bon oeil malware
oui on peut pas dire que sur arte les
rebelles
leseur regardez vous allumez producteurs
qu'on aime détester un peu comme toi
gilles tu vois là et les gens regardent
passer pareille voilà christine angot on
n'aime pas ça on n'aime pas ne pas vous
qui vient de trouver un scoop il
semblerait qu'il soit encore présent une
année de plus voilà
ouais c'est et après s'arrête